instead and so the minimum of f ofx in this case will be when the number of edges traversed by the cut is
maximal we choose to frame this problem as a minimization problem because this allows us to later map it onto an energy
minimization problem AKA finding the ground state which is what quantum computers are naturally really good at
but remember there is nothing related to Quantum Computing here yet we still need to reformulate this problem into
something that a quantum computer can understand we're now ready to syn our teeth in and begin the work and the
first step is to map the problem onto a Quantum circuit it may not seem obvious how we
are going to go from a graph like the one we just drew to a Quantum circuit but let's take this slow remember we are
going to try to solve this Max cut problem using qaoa in the qaoa algorithm we ultimately want to have an operator
the hamiltonian which will be used to represent the cost function of our problem as well as a parameterized
circuit the onot or the trial state that we will use to represent Quantum states that are educated guesses or candidates
for the solution to the problem we can sample from these candidate States and then evaluate them
using the cost function in this case the cost function is f ofx but we need to express it in a
way that feels native to the quantum computer for this we'll take advantage of a series of mathematical
transformations to express f ofx as an energy function the hamiltonian the first step of the
process is to express the problem of minimizing f ofx as a quadratic unconstrained binary optimization
problem or Cubo for short Cubo is a general way to formulate these combinatorial optimization problems
here Q is an N byn Matrix of real numbers n corresponds to the number of
nodes in our graph five for this example and X is the same Vector of binary variables from the initial
formulation to effectively run the qaoa algorithm we need to express our optimization problem in terms of a
hamiltonian which is a mathematical operator that represents the total energy of a system specifically we want
to create a cost function hamiltonian that has the property that its ground state energy or minimum igen value
corresponds to the minimum of the function which encodes the maximum number of cuts on the graph g once we
have this hamiltonian all we need to do to solve our optimization problem is to prepare the ground state of the hamiltonian on the quantum computer then
sampling from this state will with a high probability yield the solution to the minimization of f of X as it turns
out we are in luck because the Cubo problem is very closely related to and actually computationally equivalent to
one of the most famous and ubiquitous hamiltonians in physics the eing hamiltonian in order to write the Cubo
problem as this eising hamiltonian all we actually need to do is a simple variable change in order to go from
Boolean variables 0 and 1 to spin variables minus one and one this step is
straightforward it is shown in more detail in the appendix of the attached notebook for those interested but in the end the minimization of this Cubo
expression is the same as the minimization of this expression rewriting again slightly and
we have our cost function hamiltonian where the minimum of the expression represents the ground state and Z
becomes the poz operator while B is a real scalar coefficient now that we have our hand
malonian it's straightforward to rewrite it in terms of two local ZZ poly operators that will convert easily into
two cubic gates in our Quantum circuit please refer to the associated notebook to see how this is done but the output
is given by this line here note that in our example there are
six objects or po strings because each represents an edge in the graph the length of the string matches the number
of nodes so i i i ZZ is five nodes and the string will be composed of
identities in all positions except for the indices of the nodes involved in an edge which will have Z terms in Kiss kit
bit strings representing cubits are indexed backwards for example an edge between nodes 0 and 1 will be encoded as
I I I ZZ with the hamiltonian written in terms of Poes we are ready to construct our
Quantum circuit this Quantum circuit will help us sample good solutions from the quantum computer the qaoa algorithm
is inspired from the adiabatic theorem which states that if we start in the ground state of the time dependent
hamiltonian and if the hamiltonian evolves slowly enough and given enough time the final state will be the ground
state of the final hamiltonian qaoa can be thought of as the discret trotz version of the quantum
adiabatic algorithm where each trot step represents a layer which we'll call P so
instead of evolving from one state to the other in each layer of P we will switch back and forth between our cost
function hamiltonian and something called our mixer hamiltonian which we'll hear more about in just a moment but the point that I want to make
is that qaoa has the advantage of being faster than the quantum adiabatic algorithm but it returns approximate
Solutions rather than the optimal in the limit where the number of layers goes to Infinity qaoa converges to the adiabatic
case but of course this is very computationally expensive to create our Quantum circuit
we'll apply alternating operators here parameterize by gamma and beta which
will represent the discretization of the time Evolution so again the three main parts
of the qaoa circuit are one the initial trial state in Gray which is the ground
state of the mixer from the adiabatic state of ution created by applying a hadamard gate applied to every Cubit two
the cost function Evolution which we already have in dark purple and three the evolution under the mixer
hamiltonian which we have not yet discussed in light purple now our starting hamiltonian is
called the mixer because its ground state is the superposition of all possible bit strings of Interest hence
enforcing a mixture of all possible solutions at the start the mixer hamiltonian is the simple sum of Po X
operations on each node of the graph kiss kit allows you to use a different custom mixer operator if you wish but
for this case we are just going to use the standard one so again you can see that with kiss kit a lot of the work is
removed for us making coming up with the mixer hamiltonian and the starting State trivial the only work we had to do was